hybride lé monde de l'université et de
l'entreprise au service du développement
économique et de l'innovation
voici la mission essentielle de x campus
situé à saint germain en laye depuis
septembre 2021 400 salariés techniciens
ingénieurs ou chercheurs de 15
entreprises différentes évolué avec 160
étudiants de siwa et cergy paris
université l'intérêt d'avoir des
étudiants sur le campus est évidemment
pour les entreprises d'avoir ce vivier
de talents extraordinaires que sont les
étudiants et pour les autres audiences
et leur offrir un environnement très
professionnalisant puisque on propose
aux start up de proposer régulièrement
des problématiques auxquelles sont
confrontés et au lieu d'être une
problématique théorique ou d'une
entreprise qui est basé le doute la
france bat c'est une problématique très
pratique émises par une entreprise qui
est sur le campus donc on peut déjeuner
le midi on peut aller faire du sport
avec la start up qui en compte cette
problématique des contrats
d'apprentissage ou de stages seront
également noué entre les start up et les
étudiants hébergés dans le campus à la
jeunesse du projet l'entreprise x blue
dont le campus est construit autour du
site de cette société de haute
technologie française ça me permet
d'obtenir de vrais talents le développer
aussi et d'orienter les politiques
d'enseignement et de recherche vers nos
besoins qui sont qui sont très forts
puisque nous travaillons dans les hautes
technologies donc on est toujours à la
recherche de deux vraiment de talent
depuis la rentrée 2000 21 x campus
accueille deux formations de siwa et
cergy paris université dont une école de
design je me suis dit c'est l'école fait
pour moi parce que le campus on a quand
même un cadre assez agréable et puis le
fait d'être avec des entreprises
s'étaient c'était super avantageux x
campus intégral ambitions d'un nouveau
quartier universitaire pour la ville de
saint-germain-en-laye situé dans le
secteur ouest de la commune fierté pour
moi c'est de pouvoir construire ce
projet ton puces à l'échelle de notre
ville et compter d'ici quelques années
5000 étudiants avec ce navire amiral ce
coeur du réacteur quel os x campus en
janvier 2023 de nouveaux bâtiments
seront construits pour accueillir 900
salariés et 870 étudiants en doublant la
surface pour passer à 35 mille mètres
carrés